in ancient times for legendary warriors
defended the temple of the crescent moon
against all threats to Asia now as evil
arises once again IO spirit defender of
the temple calls on new heroes to unite
and protect the planet under one sky
defending the east blue dragon possesses
the ability to transform whatever she
touches into a Joe Connick weapon with
their heirloom spear weapon hand this
child of a Vietnamese noble family
leaves the warriors of the sky with her
protective spirit and wise judgment
through any challenge they may encounter
leaping from the West the massive war
tiger slices through evil with the
mystical Tigers faith this Asian tide
general ensures the success of his
fellow warriors of the sky with his
immense power and hardened combat
experience
strategizing in the north shadow shell
disables her enemies from afar and
defends her teammates with her highly
advanced rifle and bagua energy she
which a no shells adopted family and
Taiwan attempted to poison the extremely
intelligent tactician gained her unseen
powers of toxic immunity and now
provides battle strategy for the
Warriors of this
soaring into battle as guardian of the
south the searing Sun bird provides the
healing supports were the warriors of
the sky with agile charm the Malaysian
pirate from the 1600s reborn from the
power of his twin Chris's seeks to make
the most of his new life by supporting
the world however possible the warriors
of the skies coming soon